practice practice practice practice
practice practice practice
what's up believe nation today we're
gonna give you some motivation so you
can practice practice practice and as
always you know the drill if you hear
something that really resonates with you
leave it down the comments put quotes
around this or other people can be
inspired as well enjoy you look for that
thing that that that moves you I don't
know what it is I like repetition and
there's a saying goes rapid repetition
repetition keeps me green yeah I love
that saying that position keeps me green
keeps me green because fresh because the
idea that we do performance is over and
over again you would say well doesn't
that get boring or stale but no it's in
the repetition that the creation comes
that the expression comes because I'll
give you an example I was doing Richard
once not particularly well and this show
is going on and we couldn't get this
court scene with a lot of people in it I
didn't understand what I was doing in
the scene so we would call rehearsals I
would rehearse it and stuff and we would
talk about it think about it you know
like all
this kind of work where people together
trying to figure out something in the
85th performance of Richard I did on my
85th entrance
I knew the court see I understood it I I
was there I could play but not in 84 not
maybe four I was I might have been
getting closer didn't realize it yeah I
gave up the ghost I guess I just gave it
up and said oh screw it it's not gonna
happen and I'll just keep going on and I
found it I remain I'm uninterested in
that topic Tom which one whether the
relationship between gift and practice
no I want to trust it in natural gifts
and I know they exist and I know there's
such a thing as talented as neither that
but right I just feel like so and so
what right because there are people and
I always think of year about school fen
I always think of Derrick Coleman yes I
remember chatting with a guy who worked
for the Sixers and he said you have to
understand that Derrick Coleman was the
most gifted man ever to set foot on a
basketball court he said I like it you
know you've heard another a million
other names
nobody was as good as Derrick and like
who has heard today who thinks who puts
Derrick Coleman up there in the pantheon
no one he didn't want to work he had bad
habits he had a bad attitude
I mean so what give me somebody who
wants to go to practice in the morning
and he wants to try in games and I want
to celebrate him it wasn't until I
started my own team when I realized that
there are people with incredible talent
and no motivation and then there are
other people that are willing to work
their ass off who don't have a natural
ability but will become successful
because they're so determined and and I
saw it I mean I saw it especially in a
couple of guys that I first put on the
birdhouse team namely Andrew Reynolds
map each map each was in my eyes the
most naturally Thomas K border that I've
ever seen everything came easy to him
and I you know when I would request
these guys to go on tour all I ask them
is that they skate for exhibitions and
whatnot Matt wouldn't skate half the
time we'd flown to Europe I don't have
any money then you know in our company
but I was flying these guys a year or
competitions he would go to the Cantus
and not feel like skating and I was like
how can you do that you know I was just
thinking about not just to me but to
yourself like you have this incredible
talent that you just don't care and then
I saw Angie Reynolds who was the scrappy
little guy taking not very clean but in
terms of his style but trying some of
the hardest stuff taking the heaviest
hits but always skating his ass off and
always trying and he has become probably
the most well respected street skater
today Andrew Reynolds me he formed Baker
Brand Death Wish skateboards and the the
community of the the most hardcore
skaters these days call him the boss
because he developed his style because
he worked his ass off and he's the
shining example of hard work people
who've asked me that over the years you
know how do i codable or how do i bend
the ball and yeah it's something that
just happened it's not something that I
thought okay I want to bend the ball
better than anyone else so I'm gonna
kick the ball within this certain way I
just worked on my striking of the ball I
just practiced every day it's something
that I've done from a very young age you
know even after every training session
you know I take balls on on my own and
just go and kick and and and try and
find new ways of getting the ball in the
net without anyone touching it and you
know I've been lucky enough to have done
that over the years with with the way I
kick the ball and I know that it's a
unique style and I know I know it's a
unique style just because my back hurts
a little bit more than than it did when
I was 15 years old but no I you know
it's something I practice of course you
know it's one thing I tell kids and and
unless you practice you're never gonna
you know get better at something you
have to practice over the years I wasn't
great in the beginning I was I and then
I got cool and then I got good then I
got better and then I got great those
are steps to becoming great and a lot of
people ain't willing to to take those
steps it takes ten years as something
continuously to become great any and I
stuck with it for 10 years straight
before I had a record deal before I had
money
before I had lights in camera before I
had you know people wanted to sit down
and interview me I need to practice
remember before the day comes you gotta
practice you cannot be standing at the
free-throw line
playing professional basketball in the
seventh game of the NBA championship and
hope right then you're gonna be
practiced practice is too late Larry
Bird used to put the great basketball
player he used to shoot whatever
thousand free throws 8:00 in the morning
my friend Don ravine trains a lot of the
pro basketball players LeBron James he
trains he trains Durant
Toby Chris Paul and he said these guys
are up when everybody else is sleeping
they're practicing so everything you
want is gonna entail a good bit of
practice I always believed that
Knoxville talent can can take you so far
but I think you need to have the work
ethic and the drive to to achieve your
potential I mean I'd say you know my
natural talent you know probably brought
me 50% of the way
but then after that it was all it was
all done the work that I've done and I'm
the volume of work that I've done over
the you know the last 15 years you know
when I really started to take gold
seriously and you know follow boy you're
making this a career whenever you talk
about ethics and integrity in the Indian
context the two companies that come to
mind one is the Pattersons and the other
is the Profi what is so special about
these two companies that has been it has
been involved in these organizations how
is it done very simple is done by
practice there's no other way you invite
things aren't organized it is practice
integrity is practice leadership is
practice innovation is practice it's all
practice you've got to figure out what
you want your company to be and what you
consider is non compromisable not
negotiable
and they send those out and keep them as
simple as possible and keep them as few
as possible and practice them and
practice them every day every hour every
minute and have zero exception to them
the advice I give to any young kid as
anyone could play a game of football
anyone the practice makes you a real
football
you see games in a Sunday pub games Oh
whoever gave a football the real players
of the practice had thing about and well
you take that I've never been a lunch in
Glasgow many many years ago and Garret
player was a classical golfer and they
asked him a question why do you keep
practice and from the bunker because he
was famous for girls bunker I says well
I know I'm going to be the in the bunker
at one time in the game maybe twice in a
game and I've got to put in a hole is
that's why I practice and practice and
practice that's a great example of what
you have to do to be at 30 seconds left
Jordan left side our practice is if I'm
playing the game so when the moment
comes in the game it's not new to me
that's the beauty of the game of
basketball that's the reason why you
practice that's the effort so when you
get to that moment you don't have to
think instinctively things happen
8786 Michael Jordan with 45 points yes
yeah I think it was a very defining
moment of what my career was in Chicago
[Music]
six NBA championship
[Applause]
[Music]
magnificent isn't
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I love to know what did
you think what did you take from this
are you gonna work harder are you gonna
practice more you're gonna hustle more
leave in the comments below what was
your favorite clip and what did you
learn from it that you're gonna
immediately apply to your business or
life leave it in the comments I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Himanshu
preemie thank you so much you're picking
up a couple of my book you're one word
and making that awesome youtube video
around it as well I really really really
really appreciate it I encourage
everyone to read this book because this
book has actually helped me to find my
one word and I'm a hundred percent sure
that it will definitely help you find
your one word so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
beebee do you still practice yes yes I
do not not nearly enough but I play
every night practically at least for
five nights a week and I'd practice but
my practice and it's not what it should
be other words to really just get down
and play this scales on something once
or twice a week
hmm but by me playing every night
usually I'm always running into
something of accidentally falling into
something that I hadn't heard before and
then you go back and look for it later
on when you do practice what do you work
on you have any specific exercises there
uh my exercises usually it's the scales
mostly mostly bad and just all over the
the neck of the guitar because if I keep
doing it I usually will hear and you
start the plan well then you keep
hearing and you and your things that you
can play with you know something like
that and that's what I keep doing until
a fingers say stuff